semana se dieron a conocer los rosters
de los equipos que van a disputar el
clásico mundial que es el máximo torneo
de selecciones de béisbol Ahora nos
vamos a Santo Domingo para conversar con
Adelaida Hernández periodista
especializada quien saludamos Adelaida
Buenas noches un placer estar con
ustedes vemos en estos rosters que se
han anunciado por ejemplo que dominicana
tiene grandes estrellas pero también
ausencias que van a ser costosas vemos
un México que luce fuerte igual
Venezuela qué podemos destacar de estas
nóminas que conocemos hasta el momento
en lo que se refiere a la pelota del
Caribe
tenemos unas ausencias importantes pero
también tenemos unos jugadores que yo
siento que van realmente el trabajo que
nosotros necesitamos como país que se
haga tenemos ausencia importante pero eh
tenemos la suficiente material en
República Dominicana por ejemplo
podríamos destacar que no podría ser
mucha falta un José Ramírez pero José
Ramírez por ejemplo acaba de salir de
una lesión y tú sabes Cuáles son las
reglas del clásico mundial cuando un
pelotero tiene problemas de lesión pues
lamentablemente no puede estar en el
equipo franber Valdez no quiere estar
porque dice que está cansado tenemos la
ausencia de Luis Severino tenemos a Luis
Castillo que parece ser que la
organización le sugirió como que no
jugara Porque ninguna organización puede
prohibirlo pero sí sugerirlo parece que
le sugirieron que no jugara tenemos una
ausencia importante también Emmanuel
clase que su organización sí
Aparentemente le ha prohibido jugar
relevos que van a ser muy importante
pero también tenemos un staff de relevo
donde la República Dominicana realmente
Bueno si tú te fijas en el la serie
mundial todos los relevistas de los ex
de los astros de Houston Perdón fueron
lo que realmente le dieron el triunfo a
los astros de Houston iban a hacer lo
que van a estar en el clásico con
nosotros
Adelaida de los equipos de grandes ligas
han impuesto restricciones en cuanto al
uso de los jugadores a lo largo de este
clásico mundial
esas restricciones van a afectar a todos
por igual o va a haber equipos con más
limitaciones
Le repito la pregunta hay restricciones
por parte de los equipos de grandes
ligas para el uso de los jugadores estas
restricciones estas limitaciones afectan
a todos los equipos por igual o va a
haber alguno más afectado por ejemplo el
caso dominicana con Sandy Alcántara
yo creo Bueno
hasta ahora no se le ha prohibido jugar
hasta ahora tengo entendido que está
dentro de nosotros pero déjame decirte
que yo pienso que quizás el menos
afectado de todos los equipos que van a
estar en el clásico son los Estados
Unidos porque tienen el 90%
o sea realmente ahí hay congruencia si
se puede decir así porque nosotros
tenemos
Porque organizaciones les sugieren que
no jueguen pero también tenemos un gran
cantidad de talento que podríamos hacer
dos equipos fácilmente
No creo que nos veamos tan afectados
porque realmente el material que tenemos
muy muy bueno pero tengo entendido que
Sandy Alcántara hasta el momento está
aprobado por su organización para y de
hecho él ha dicho que va a abrir el
primer partido Sí pero va a jugar
probablemente dos partidos solamente no
hay que administrarlo
exacto no eso por lógica porque es que
son prácticamente campos de
entrenamiento Ellos están comenzando
después de una ausencia de meses del
béisbol se termina en octubre arranca
los campos de entrenamiento febrero la
viene siendo once de marzo el clásico
Mundial de Béisbol tienen pocos días ya
entrenando y hay que irnos tres cuatro
entradas no más de tres y medio
en principio Pero quizás en una segunda
salida ya podrían ir un poquito más
extenso de cuatro a seis entradas no más
de ahí porque también el equipo tiene
que administrarlo Pero tenemos
suficiente lanzadores para suplir esa
ese ese orden Porque por ejemplo tenemos
un Cristian Javier que puede hacer de
abridor en cualquier momento hizo hizo
de relevo con los astros